[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
why don't you we got a lot of a lot of
females this time too many if you ask me
we gotta get rid of some of these FEMA
I'm just kidding around here just
joshing just getting the uh Halloween
spirit up we're gonna have a good time
we're gonna have a spooky good time as
the lights turn off uh well on this show
we always have a guest and uh this week
we have a very very funny comedian all
the way from New York City she's been
killing it all over town opened up for
Joe Rogan recently uh give it over the
very funny comedian it's Gina hyena
Gina thank you so much for doing this
show getting to yell at men for how
shitty they are at dating
um any any crazy things happen over the
recent few weeks four months well I just
took a trip with my friend meaning and
we did we allegedly ate some mushrooms
last night oh a psychedelic trip yeah
and it's a travel agent what was that
yeah
one I can't send you the name to
um
no but it was horrible so I ended up
puking my ass off last night so here I
am without makeup on and just get to
judge you guys I can't wait for it it's
like being a fly on the wall for your
friends is so fun well that's two of us
without makeup on
we're out here makeupless just judging
you uh let's see who we got in the
bucket
do you want to pick the female I'll pick
the male
not a lot of males today
I'm shy men this looks like it was
written by a serial killer oh no look at
the pen was having a hard time all right
Carissa
Carissa the serial killer there's
something going on today because it's
the pin she's having a bad pen day
and it's Grampy
just come on right up the stairs over
there
run through
[Music]
famously Whitney stages of the creek in
the cave
and feel free to sign up anytime
throughout the show one minute of dating
Starts Now
pick up the mics and start trying to
[ __ ] each other
your name my name's Graham oh yeah yeah
your name's Carissa right yeah I'm not a
serial killer I hope
what did you write that made them think
that the pen is broken
no like um pentagrams or anything
I forgot
what do you do what do I do I'm in I.T
I'm a engineer network engineer I work
at home oh do you like it I love it yeah
definitely
yeah what do you do
um I'm a hostess at a restaurant okay
how's the food it's pretty good most the
time most of the time
of Comedy he's just been sitting in his
apartment
sad without any comedy in his life just
I.T all day where do you work for it
what company
staffing companies oh okay that sounds
vague yeah a lot of usually are both
like the sweetest most quiet people and
now I just feel horrible
yeah you loser
I wish you guys were a meaner you said
uh he said did you write pentagrams on
the slip and then and then uh Carissa
you said I forgot you forgot to write
pentagram
how are you uh how are you celebrating
Halloween this year
um me and my friends went out last night
but it was a bust
what do you mean a bus right now we're
here what happened there was there was
no no Grams Graham peas out there no
unfortunately
you're in luck Halloween Eve you know
what they say did you dress up I did but
were you I was a cowgirl cute cute where
are you from originally I'm from Wichita
Falls
is that in Wichita Kansas no it's Texas
oh [ __ ]
you guys need to come up with your own
city names goddamn taxes
confusing the [ __ ] out of me
um that's cool so you actually are a
cowgirl because you're from Texas yeah
have you ever done any any texts and
things you Wrangle any cattle I work on
a farm occasionally
uh the occasional Farm oh grant were you
dressing up for Halloween
no I don't have a Halloween costume no
no if you did have one you had all the
money in the world what would you be
uh
uh probably some recognizable character
from a show wait what character uh Finn
from Adventure Time Finn from Adventure
Time which one is that is the little
ears that's the dude the little boy yeah
and walk around town I would be a little
boy for Halloween Carissa how do you
feel about little boys for Halloween
uh not preferable he said no thank you
well you passed the test Chris Hanson
you can go home now Carissa is not the
serial killer that we thought she was so
if you two were on a dating app and you
saw each other would you swipe right or
left
who goes first
[Laughter]
uh Crystal you can go first
um probably right
right oh that's cute so you think you're
gonna exchange info after this maybe
have a little maybe another really quiet
conversation
you go to the library for your next date
where are you from Grant
I'm from Madison Wisconsin oh you're
both from places I don't really know
about in the middle of the country so
Madison Wisconsin Wichita Falls
wow such boring cities
um
you got you got good food most of the
time at your restaurant
okay Grant what was the worst breakup
you ever had
me yeah I got cheated on really bad oh
yeah really bad really bad how black was
this guy
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh
they they're I mean like my ex's husband
is
your ex had a husband I think you were
she was cheating on her husband with you
oh
well after the breakup she got married
she married the guy she cheated on you
with uh there were three main people
involved
um one of them were really really bad
her current husband they were more just
like friends during all this
um and then once we were uh no longer
together they got together and got
married
damn God that's awful how did you find
out
how did I find out yeah uh she told me
one day she was polyamorous I need to
accept her for the person she is and uh
hell yeah the non-consensual polyamory
yeah surprise you've been polyamorous
Carissa how do you feel about this
uh that's pretty pretty terrible that's
awful yeah maybe you guys could trauma
Bond
yeah what was your worst breakup Carissa
this guy we were never together but he
ended up
um crashing his car getting a DWI went
to jail and then when I met him
afterwards he said he had a girlfriend
now
he met her in jail his name was Gustavo
that's so wild oh all right so you both
had some Duds you're both sweet people
from places we don't know about where I
just expected it's cool
oh damn okay I thought you guys are
sisters very young looking mother
puzzles together
you know go go bird scootering but go to
a museum
all right all right I think we got you
guys are too nice give it up for Carissa
and Greg we're gonna go around getting
uh people to uh yeah try to force people
Caleb is a man and he's coming up on
stage to do some dating yeah it is Caleb
best questions for Rose I got Rose
there's a link from the front row
Caleb and Rose
[Music]
side hug
a little touchy already
and go
hi Rose how's it going it's
it is gone happy Halloween almost
happy Halloween it's my favorite holiday
what about you oh it's up there would
you go as so far you're outfit's been I
was Chucky Chucky Gemini
fake knife a stage knife I didn't want
to get turned away from bars you know
and any other characters uh well it's a
bit pandering but I figured with the
hair I could be Steve from stranger
things uh yeah I could see that a little
bit you could be like all the kids from
stranger things at the same time
uh yeah you look I don't know like is
that an insult you're definitely not
what did you go uh uh as a child
molester yeah nice so you and I were
gonna hit it off aren't we uh I went as
my YouTube channel
you have a YouTube channel it's a
pretend one it's not so real so do you
live here in Austin are you visiting
yeah I just I moved here uh about a
month ago but let's go back to your fake
YouTube channel what's that about oh
that's a red flag for me so well I it's
a it's a new tube as they say and I just
post videos on I don't know what are
people doing give it up for Caleb and
Rose they went on a date for a minute
I don't know what was worse you saying
you're a child molester or are you
saying you have a YouTube channel yeah
they go hand in hand I don't trust you
for [ __ ] right off the bat he was too
what do you do Caleb
uh I am either homeless or YouTube or
comedy I'm one of those three what do
you do so we'll go with homeless because
it's a combination what do you do
besides to make women uncomfortable in
bars that's most of what I aim to do so
it's weird
yeah you're doing great well we got the
[ __ ] yeah
this is what we wanted right sorry Rose
Rosa you kept it together the whole time
you said [ __ ] this [ __ ] right off the
bat just decided to start dating about
three days ago after uh taking a two and
a half year long break and this is the
place to do it and you're the guy
apparently oh yeah I'm happy groundhog
saw its shadow and now it's going back
he said no maybe we should get the lgbtq
person up for her it might be better
oh really yeah and then you got him I
got him yeah What A Catch damn yeah
that's cool yeah you uh probably
shouldn't tell women that you're dating
that they look like little boys from
stranger things I said all the kids
Elle's in there she's a girl not better
at the same time
really oh yeah I'm a pretty
uncomfortable I guess Caleb what was
your last date like
uh my last date uh we went to a wine bar
hung out it was pretty good I guess did
you do a lot of whining oh I guess wait
does this count because this is still
ongoing what did you mean by last please
don't interrupt the jokes to say nothing
yes sir uh
so yeah you had a fake knife Rose that's
that's a smart move you don't want to go
in with a real knife I don't think about
dirty not first date you know
yes Caleb where are you from I moved
here from Salt Lake City
the mountains I'm a Utah I can't say
that so are you actually homeless or was
that you trying to be funny
I'm on my way I'm I seem to be doing
everything no I'm I'm moving I'm I'm
trying to figure out where my home is
that's where I'm at yeah
were you a catch in Salt Lake City
well I don't know if you've seen the
competition but no what happened this is
the first person I've seen well you can
download the dating apps and judge for
yourself I guess I don't need advice
from you Caleb lost your [ __ ] mouth
I'm asking the questions
all right so you go hiking the money
what bright Austin
I just wanted to come and uh
uh hang out and be a part of the comedy
scene and the tech scene and I thought
it was a cool City and I was right
the tech scene
there's a Texas why would you want to be
part of the tech scene oh that's my
background that's what I used to do
before all that okay all this stuff you
seemed very robotic so do I just not get
any questions yeah you can ask a
question would you like to ask who do
who would you like to ask a question to
you
yeah so about your last date you said
you guys went to a winery Etc
um at what point did you chop her up and
eat her yeah that was like well past
midnight that was the next day no I uh
it was fun we had we had fun we just
walked around the city yeah what was
your last date
it was over like
two and a half that's not possible you
didn't run into somebody in a park in
two years I just have not been accepting
dates
okay Oliver Caleb this is blowing
Caleb's mind right now
to a date yeah it was like we want to
hang out I've never heard a girl say no
behind the muffled gags that I put in
their mouth
Rose where are you from I'm from Turkey
oh oh that's why you have your composure
about you he said [ __ ] this guy
turkey oh my God wouldn't you come to
Texas
uh Texas it's been a while yeah yeah
how's were you old enough to date in
Turkey
uh by his standards definitely oh [ __ ]
she just called you a pedophile I put
myself in this box I put myself I
absolutely did you said you went you
went to Halloween as a child molester
did it take a lot of makeup or did you
go no no no not as much as you think
yeah yeah that's how it is I just kind
of had everything on hand
have you ever the only thing I had I
needed was the mustache
I would say like a tip for you I would
have on a date is like try to Blink more
I don't know if you've ever tried
methamphetamine but kind of gets in the
way of blinking oh you just get worse
every time it's
Gina really doesn't like you
um what it was the snappy [ __ ] right
from the start it's just disingenuous
well uh I'll be more genuineous or
Genuine guy with a tech degree yeah
everything is like an engineer to me
it's all wiring and code and under there
oh Rose you're cool as [ __ ] I'm so sorry
this happened to you she is cool Rose is
super chill we all know that okay love
it's you we're worried oh well I mean
I'm just hanging out Caleb what's the
most genuine thing you can say right now
popcorn champion
popcorn Champion there we go
I have no idea I have no idea you can't
come
up uh what's Real uh is something
genuine
yes tell us one thing yeah well I need a
prompt give me a topic or something
what's the most embarrassing thing that
you can admit to right now uh a lot I've
LED assorted life
um please pick one of the most
embarrassing I'll give you a Halloween
one you guys want a Halloween one yes I
we're on a date you okay well right okay
so here's my Halloween one I was uh I
think in fifth grade and I was a mummy
where you like do a bunch of layers
basically and we had to do this parade
for like 30 minutes and the whole time I
had to pee and I was doing everything
crossing my legs and like bending over
and you know whatever I could do to make
it
and I almost did I got like to the
bathroom and it was the unwrapping of
the layers of the Mummy outfit that got
me and I pissed my pants right there in
that bathroom do you don't have a dad
after that I didn't he left
okay
he's like I almost
damn
I did you're in fifth grade you have a
peed costume what do you do
well what have I got like I gotta ride
the bus home
so now I have like this peed outfit that
I have to like ride the stinky bus and
anyway lots of paper towels lots of
water from the sink I figured it out is
fine that was uh but I did get Scarlet
oh you're not done are you done yet
keeps going that was just that was a
really that was a really embarrassing
a whole Australian accent and you
decided to come here and go what's your
name to her you could have had a
Charming Australian accent and he did
some [ __ ] drums
I'm sorry no sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
yeah that was my back well
um yeah I have no excuse emka you look
shocked and I feel bad for doing this to
you now I know we're gonna get a real
date up here we're gonna wait so is your
how do you you're Australian your
friends from [ __ ] Ohio how did that
happen uh people move yeah I know that
[ __ ] not according to you
I'm trying to stop that house
um yeah you said I'm a [ __ ] and I'm
allowed to say that because I'm a
[ __ ] and then he's Australia or are
you [ __ ] I'm Donald Trump yeah by the
way you're [ __ ] I'm character Trump
wants to be brown it's not orange is
that I'm high
I'm high Trump doesn't get high doesn't
he no he hates weed
well I didn't tell you what I was high
on well it's probably weed I don't know
judging by you you're from Peru and
Australia not on Adderall because you
would be much more clever than this
how long did you escape Australia uh I
just escaped it in July did you guys
really have that [ __ ] where you had to
check in on your phone where you were
yeah that's crazy you still have it no
we don't want to see it this is a show
if you want to see the app on my phone
no bro we are in front of an audience
right now this is America your phone
will blow up if you pull that [ __ ] up
over here yeah I know especially got
freedoms here so the freedom I want to
give my citizens what do you go in and
out of your character yeah yeah it's
wild what do you do I'm bipolar I'm
Donald Trump I'm checking out oh I hate
how guys think that's cute now to be
like
okay it's a character
all right so it's always the worst when
they're like I have anxiety you have
anxiety no I said the guys when they're
like yeah they're ready every day all
day I'm like I don't know I don't get
inside when do they get anxiety guys
anxiety people apparently lately really
yeah you should go to Peru on Saturday
goes away really quickly there you
should go to Peru is what this man said
I don't realize pull the makeup closer
to your mouth so we can hear your
[ __ ] more
um he's not used to technology yeah what
do you what do you do what is your job
my job I don't have one
he's like the real Trump
I am I am a real estate bro not in New
York in Lima Peru I build buildings I
don't realize Trump was so sweaty yeah I
know I'm just sold it back I said
are you done I'm done
God what's your type
is it bleach just taller than me please
yeah
me
it's one I think is that is that why you
said it he's six one six six you're six
oh what would you say in centimeters
kangaroos or eight one kangaroos or
whatever the [ __ ] one llama yeah one
lamb at all seven koalas
I don't know there we go what was the
last date that you've been on I heard it
was recently yeah this morning oh oh
[ __ ] what'd you do I don't know we woke
up together that's all I remember oh
I'm gonna had a night
talking about them [ __ ] cells over
here IMCA getting it in gotta get it in
hell yeah girl is that last night yeah
good how was he in the morning
I'm like okay that was a mistake oh no
that's the worst [ __ ] what character was
he playing
oh my God [ __ ] was he just talking too
much or was he just like not your type
yeah not my type what character was he
wearing a costume from last night
no
he said I just took my beer goggles off
and I got to see I woke up this morning
uh sober yeah that's all it takes and he
was at your place no his uh what was his
place like tell us describe the inside
to us
I mean
it's clean was fine did he have a bed
frame
um no no Welcome to Austin everybody
he's got a poster hung up with thumb
tags like gosh we still got a Fight Club
my room was next to my room was pretty
loud in the hostel it's just banging
you're in the hostel
okay if you like shut up you have like
good bone structure but every time
Jesus every time you talk you're like
I'm broke I'm gonna try to do this
[ __ ] accent and then call myself a
wet back when I'm Australian you psycho
Australian
psycho you should go out and just not
talk and I bet you'd get like done that
a few times it's Psychopathic but it's
nothing nothing really happens sexism
has gone full circle now men are being
told to shut up and smile
yeah that's exactly right actually I saw
some guy beat up last night no the other
night across the road at the sidebar you
just got punched by a chick because she
wanted to pick him up and he didn't want
to so things have come around they don't
do that in Australia no no no not yet
what did you do in Australia
property development
can you like be quiet for a second
property development same thing as
Donald Trump did in New York but in
Australia and much less successful which
is hard to do because Donald Trump
wasn't very good at his job he was
terrible his job well actually he was
pretty rude well not if he's he created
he created mine a which is pretty
interesting we're probably he stole it
from someone okay did you and your
friend just go on Wikipedia before you
came here not before I mean like in the
audience God emka where did you meet the
guy that you got [ __ ] by did you get
watched I'm sorry
I was like I'm sorry I just needed him
to stop talking
where'd you meet the guy online Facebook
oh Facebook dating yeah I haven't used
it yet I have a friend that works for
Facebook dating Facebook has a dating
app yeah you [ __ ] see oh [ __ ]
everyone get on Facebook dating now
Donald Trump has found it
yeah good talent good talents funny
stories it's been great I just do it for
the funny stories
good talent
well Donald Trump would
a lot of your supporters are on Facebook
so you would probably do well in
Facebook dating apps thanks Hans
uh okay so you met him on Facebook and
then uh did you guys go to any Halloween
parties together
um yeah oh that's how it all started ooh
fun in the bars or did you go to a house
party it was a house party oh fun fun
fun it was in the 70s which I hate but
yeah it was 70s like this party was
somebody's Halloween party yeah I don't
know the whole look like really yeah
that's weird there's a lot of other
better things to do
he said let's get out of here
huh well MK is awesome that's why she's
getting it in you and your friend should
just be quiet because your friend has a
beard and you have good bone structure
so I think that counts as me saying
something nice
what do you got
um
you look like uh Donald Trump if it was
in No Country for Old Men
but give it up for emka and Donald J
Trump thank y'all thank you and former
president that was
thank you
let's get another couple up here we got
that's Donald Trump
he was a Hispanic Donald Trump we got
Frank Garza a real name yeah
I got Melinda coming up here
Melinda Gates
Melinda get your ass up here
well Linda is a little bit shy Melinda's
very shy
where is she Melinda we can't see
Melinda we're not going on with the show
until you come up here
I'll probably say that man you're the
nicest guy we've had
since Donald Trump
where is Melinda
Linda Belinda Melinda you're
killing me are you Melinda
you're Melinda right
come on up here Melinda
I'm just pointing at that lady over
there all right Melinda make an answer
she's a devil but she doesn't I got Anna
Anna
here she comes Anna
way better than that
[Music]
I forgot I put my name in there
and go you have the last the same last
name as me oh that that could be a
really bad sign yeah I have a lot of
cousins yeah I do too where are you from
uh Chicago originally okay now I'm from
Mexico oh this was my dad oh okay yeah
not a good sign
um what part of Mexico North Mexico
oh good Bordertown
okay yeah you live in San Antonio no no
I live in Austin oh did you just live in
San Antonio no I got it like a few
months ago just for fun I don't I don't
really like San Antonio either
I I think it's lame I just don't like it
I lived there for 10 years Austin is
much better yeah I agree I know I love
Austin yeah
so where'd you come here from
um here yeah yeah
um
McAllen
McAllen Texas
yeah Austin's not great for you what
Austin's done yeah yeah 100 yeah
are we done
wow so shy at time he finally reached
the minute it felt like a lot longer
yeah it did give it up for Frank Garza
and Anna
they're related this is a perfect
Southern date
that's awesome you guys are both from
the same area north Mexico no we're not
AKA Texas
um
yeah this is great uh wild wait a
certain date
you have the same last name as me that's
her opener
do a little 23andMe to start the date
out
foreign that's cool uh so Frank how does
it feel having a new boss at Twitter
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah it makes you think I work for
Twitter your autism all of it
good guess but no
no way what you're working Tech I had no
idea
what do you do
software development let's get a little
bit Hardware development
that's too hard anyways uh Anna what do
you do I do Neuroscience research I
study the brains of people nice where
are you doing research uh dell Med oh
nice work down here yeah it's so pretty
that's a pretty hospital so we have to
go to the hospital go to delcene oh yeah
I need my brain like that
someone is trying to [ __ ] her brother
uh
that's cool someone's uh helping the
world and someone's uh trying to destroy
free speech out here
uh what kind of software are you
developing
[Music]
contractor work for Center for Medical
Medicare I have no idea what you said
contract word for center for Medicare
service so I I work for Medicare oh okay
oh you guys are in the same sort of
field
he does the computer stuff you do the
actual
brand stuff
saving lives
that's cool
so yeah so uh Frank
what brought you to Austin and where did
you come from before this
was living in San Antonio performing
with Austin I met a wonderful woman via
some online activities and I thought I
should uh move up here and you're a fan
of a porn star
no but uh I mean maybe but that's that's
not the woman I was dating yeah you got
to support sex workers man of course
but unfortunately that relationship did
not work out so and now you're stuck
here in Austin with your ex just bumping
into each other going on dates on stage
cool cool
wait so what happened that it didn't
work out
is the juice
she got a crush on someone else
what did that guy do work for Twitter
no he was actually a co-worker at first
oh what did she do she was also a
software at a different company oh drama
in the software World bam you found the
one software developer that's a woman
and the other one snatched her away
I couldn't say she developed a crush
like you're in fifth grade
I think she was [ __ ] someone else
dude oh
anyways Anna what do you think about all
this
I'm okay with it
that's fine my boyfriend's in over there
so I have to be careful with what I say
oh no are you in an abusive relationship
right now blink twice
I'm not
oh so you came with your boyfriend and
y'all were just like let's do this it'll
be fun are y'all polyamorous no oh no no
no no not that you know here to tease
our
audience like haha we're happy he just
came to watch you guys
oh that's how long have you and your
boyfriend been together um
um uh like officially dating for three
months oh how about unofficially dating
six what made it official
um we just decided it was gonna be
official like Facebook official or like
we just said now he's my boyfriend no no
I don't I don't think we have each other
on Facebook yet
well that's good because that's where a
lot of people are meeting up to [ __ ]
during Halloween apparently
me might develop a crush
oh I have a crush on you Circle yes if
you feel the same way about me
that's cool Frank you're how old are you
you could either be 24 or 39.
wow that's probably mathematically
correct you did that real quick
it's like the battle of the two brains
[ __ ] math I don't be the smarter one
what's the nerdiest thing that you do do
you play chess online I do play chess
what's your yellow
uh it's one or it's 17.50 loser I like
that he said what's the nerdiest thing
you do yeah well what's your ELO like
I have no idea what that is but I'll
challenge her
what's your yellow I don't play chess
I play Settlers
yeah I'm Hans Neiman I just changed my
last name to come on this show
I have an anal beat in me right now
on a Sunday
[Laughter]
the Lords the priests put it in there
himself oh
anyways all right Anna do you go to
church
what about Iglesia
yeah
see
uh Frank are you religious or do you
worship at the altar of uh Elon Musk
neither
is it a simulation are we in a
simulation
I don't think so yeah
this guy's got it all figured out yeah
he would know
[Laughter]
life what's your ELO and life do you
think
I have no one what's ELO it's like how
good you are at things
description
it's like your SAT score for versions
that are 30 35.
what
it's a it's just a measure of uh skill
you can use it for other games but
people use it for chess oh yeah okay
everybody I think if I go and
what is your boyfriend dummies only do
you know what anilo is okay cool he's
too busy getting [ __ ]
three months of unofficial [ __ ]
it's so funny
what would you describe your boyfriend
as in a high school click is it the jock
is it a stoner
um neither preppy he's
he's just amazing the most amazing I
didn't know that was a click
how did y'all meet hinge oh
better than Facebook yep
I've never tried Facebook
then knock until you try it
a lot of uh people trying to sell things
sell rocking chairs and [ __ ] on there
um Frank what's your dating history like
so far
[Music]
okay
what uh what what is your like wait are
you single
yeah you didn't come up here like a tea
like couples come
out I'm just being a [ __ ] that's like
my thing yeah thank you
she's from Massachusetts it's just how
they talk it's fine
she's about to get shot in Texas but no
I'm just kidding yeah that was horrible
it wasn't even a joke you're like you're
about to get shot that's a cool thing
yeah my uh
my instincts are way off
in terms of uh whatever anyways Frank
any tips on on me for me on how to like
talk to ladies
oh why would you say that
I ride with my ELO score apparently
that's a bad thing to do well I
technically I brought it up
what what do you like to what's your
go-to conversation topic when you're on
a date with a woman
um mostly just ask them about their
experiences in Austin and what they like
to do because everyone's new to Austin
like I haven't encountered any natives
yet we had one we had Mama native
yeah oh over there Mama native she's
busy and Austin
maybe native she produced it
she is a native and she makes natives
so um yeah I mean you hold the mic very
officially like this is like this is
where it goes what it does is not gonna
move
uh is that sort of how you have sex you
just sort of leave it in there
efficient way to [ __ ] a woman
oh no
but my friend there in the audience
knows my ex I really can't say without
like you know revealing too much
information the ACT is oh your eggs I
thought you said my friend now they
knows my act like you had like a
algorithm of things that you do to [ __ ]
somebody efficiently and I was like oh
but no it's just you don't you don't
have a move that you want to tell us
about like something that you do the
Frank Garza yeah
there is no special Frank Garza move
unfortunately
what's your top category in porn
I love how he laughs
oh so humorous
normal edsm stuff no normal BDSM what a
freak
I see a lot of room in a party yeah
clearly there's no one expected that
from you
they didn't even think that you knew how
to have sex
you said normal BDSM
Marissa
of course
I said of course
oh wow I feel dominated already Frank
you have strong Dom Energies
we're out of here
I am uncomfortable
oh you said I'm a Dom of course we did
not know the of course from this whole
interaction you got like leather daddy
[ __ ] and all that
nothing that extreme oh well what's the
extreme is it just like cable wires for
the internet your time [ __ ]
ethernet cords
normal rope
that I'm shocked right now
oh my God so you probably know how to do
a bunch of different knots too because
you're a smart guy
so technically tying those ropes
I know some stuff I think we've been
super Advanced but yeah is this not a
normal thing that people do
no
do you like slap women and stuff
if they're into it sure well he aims to
please
efficiently
okay what's efficient for you
yeah Define efficient
um I suppose what turns women on in a
way that's quickly oh okay yeah so
you're thinking about them that's good
you want the maximum Returns on
investment
I just saw you become like you know less
scared oh you're thinking about other
people good yeah I'm just beating women
because you know you enjoy it oh you're
asking them if you can tie them up
that's a good sign
this is what Caleb could be like in 10
years
honest yeah just uh
I pride myself on being a very Frank
person
yeah you're a Frank you're Frank Garza
I'm Frank and I keep it Frank that's
cool and I tie [ __ ] up
have you ever done this in real life or
do you just watch it on the internet no
I've done it in real life I like that
every woman in the audience leaned
forward
everybody got on your side immediately
oh [ __ ] and where you came from San
Antonio I'm originally from Chicago but
I was in San Antonio
you're just lasso and [ __ ]
oh that's wild oh who knew who knew the
tech guy was a dumb that's dope
we're here for you we're here for you
Frank
I think you're a crowd favorite judging
by the body language in the office yeah
everybody just went Rose is interested
he's like a man that's almost a woman
that's awesome Anna so what's the
freakiest thing you and your boyfriend
do in bed
I don't want to talk about that yeah you
don't have to it's so weird when you ask
the woman too I know
another single woman for Frank I feel
bad yeah Frank's dope let's get another
chance yeah let's get another uh woman
for Frank let's try to get Franklin
[Laughter]
the show has turned into get Franklin
give it up for Anna
and her boyfriend and her boyfriend show
we get it we love each other
they're they're making out right now
Chloe Chloe we got a Chloe in the
audience Chloe here she comes
a human female hopefully single the best
one so far
here she is Chloe and Frank Garza going
on a date for one minute hello Chloe Hi
how are you doing excellent it's very
embarrassed bro monsters like me so it's
all good that's a very interesting
spider tattoo it's fake oh nice I was
Eddie Munson last night for Halloween so
I got the the bat tattoos on this side
and his spider tattoo awesome
yeah I went out with some friends and
just kind of you know kicked it nice
you seem like a nice guy I might as well
lay down all the stuff about me hope you
know I'm a comedian so hope you're into
a good roast
um recently single you actually know my
ex he was on your podcast a couple weeks
ago
so that's gonna be interesting
and I'm autistic as [ __ ] so oh that's
just like my ass hope you don't mind
anything I need to know about you bring
it to the table
have you ever really been pretty uh yeah
yeah yeah a lot of stuff that I didn't
really want to know I kind of feel like
I'm gonna be the next Gabby Patito is
that the best thing you could have just
ran away when they called your name you
didn't have to come up here up here yeah
you're right I should have
kind of getting that Vibe and time give
it up for Chloe and Frank Garza
Frank I Think You're Gonna Want to tie
this one down if you know what I mean
hey oh
keep her from running away Chloe who's
your ex
I don't want to name drop but if you
really want to know I'll tell you after
the show oh that's not fun for everybody
here we want the tea but he is a
comedian so a good one yeah oh who is
your friends with them on yeah that's
nice of you to say I would be like no he
sucks [ __ ] him no no we're still good it
was a it was a real nice breakup real
civil he just has some stuff that he
needs to work on we're still real close
so okay yeah a lot of a lot of uh men
have a lot of things they get to work on
yeah Frank has been working on his knots
recently very naughty of you
[Laughter]
so Chloe what uh how long have you been
in Austin uh so I'm actually from Texas
I live in Temple
okay sorry
it's not even San Marcos no it's not
it's the opposite way oh is it
not even Pflugerville
doesn't even have a Panda Express no but
you do get shot out there
personal experience
you got shot I've been shot yeah Whoa by
who Frank is getting turned on yeah
yeah when I was seven I was shot
you must have been a bad seven-year-old
for like a no no I was just writing
these two older kids were like hey
you're never gonna see your mom again
and they just right in the ankle how old
are these children they were like 13 14.
they got a shot in the ankle would
prevent you from seeing your mom again I
think you know
Cuban
they're Puerto Rican but same thing
there's Puerto Ricans in Texas
I didn't know that
why don't they have a parade here ever
that's crazy a Puerto Rican shot you in
the ankle yeah
whoa you're like huh did they get caught
or get in trouble we tried but they ran
uh what we found good old run away from
yeah they stole I guess their parents
nine millimeters so and they thought it
was a toy
so they thought it was a toy they
thought it was a toy that sounds sauce
I'm assuming that's just what they're
clean yeah to shoot someone on a bike in
the ankle is probably the hardest place
to shoot someone on a bike well they
pushed me down and then it was like oh
Point Blank but it came in like an angle
it was great you know the PTSD has been
has been a thrill these past 25 years so
you know yeah whenever you see a Puerto
Rican every time you see a bison my
stepdad's Puerto Rican so yeah every
time he comes around I just shut down
you just cover your ankles right
uh so is Frank your type
um
Frank don't look at her like that
he's staring holes into her right now
don't make it
say you have autism yeah what I'm
looking at Frank and I'm looking at you
yeah where's the difference between you
and I Hans I actually accept my autism
you run from yours
hey I'm not autistic I'm Asian
Mr is going off
well you know game recognized game there
you go I dropped a puzzle right now
which one you would build it faster
[Music]
but I ain't seen it yet
throw a Rubik's Cube at both y'all
Gina's surrounded by autism right now
there you go
[Laughter]
none it's like physically I don't think
you can can you or pussy's never been
drier
she's holding all the Swagger on the
stage right now
she's resisting the urge to bully all of
us right now
she wants to give us a wedgie and a
swirly I feel like the Rubik's Cube
thing was enough I really don't believe
half y'all because you mean Italian
[ __ ] up you're chilling and you're
like on stage [ __ ] chilling and I
believe you
okay I'm the only one that's really
autistic
where's the Neuroscience girl come
diagnose them
she said bye her and her boyfriend were
like this was weird as [ __ ] up just go
[ __ ] all those losers are trying to talk
to each other God
hmm so Chloe what do you do here in
Austin now for survival
I just yeah I just do comedy okay so
you're homeless pretty much you're doing
comedy full-time I do comedy yeah I do
comedy pretty much full-time I'm out
here about five times five times out of
the week uh on the side I provide ABA
therapy for autistic kids so you know
what they say you know blind leading the
blind
even
what was that oh yeah it was weird she's
got the most street cred in any autistic
Community right
she's like I got shot in the ankle
that's like in the hood that's nothing
but yeah
Frank are you uh would you say you're a
gangster
[Laughter]
what I can tell what's the most gangster
thing that you you've done in your life
besides tying [ __ ] up I think
how do you uh get along with
African-American people
all the African-Americans I know we're
like Tech workers right like I'm
selecting for odd people right all right
I got a question for you okay [ __ ] Mary
kill Rosa Parks MLK Nelson Mandela go
I mean those are all black people
exactly one is a woman yeah honest
answers only I don't want to like marry
or
your [ __ ] man so I'm kind of tired
like this is a hard question I think I'd
have to marry Rosa Parks like that's
like multiple sacks right like
breaking news Frank Garza wants to tie
up Rosa Parks
civil rights later there's no way out of
this I just wanted to see how racist you
were
yeah I think I'd like you know [ __ ]
Nelson Mandela okay and I guess I've
killed I'm okay cause he's gonna get
like killed anyways yeah I mean here's
your shot
yeah you just got a question you asked
on dates
like I said I'm autistic it just comes
to mind
what's the brain moving there you go
Frank Garza just got a job at the FBI
right now so he wants to kill uh MLK
so uh yeah where do you stand on uh you
know uh civil rights and stuff you uh
you voting this election uh uh probably
I have not done early voting yet but
I'll probably vote on Election Day I'm
generally in favor of civil rights whoa
calm down there your liberal pansy
that's cool civil rights is important uh
Chloe so uh are you like uh like
interested in dating another comedian or
are you looking more for like a tech
worker are you all battling it out right
now
which autism couldn't date each other
because like someone needs to be able to
make oh no we had so much fun I love
dating comedians yeah if you can make me
laugh I'm sold
when you hear that ladies yeah data
comedian um you laugh at me is that
sufficient or do I have to like
intentionally make you laugh
both
I guess yeah
I just want someone who's genuine can
make me laugh at the end of the day
don't date Caleb then yeah for real the
worst stuff that sucks or Fidel Castro
so uh Frank I would love to hear if
you're gonna dress up for Halloween yeah
probably going to be a plague doctor
okay oh nice
all that Tech money you just buy a
costume
so you're gonna wear whole mask the
whole night and the goggles are you
gonna wear the goggles it's just cold
enough yes oh then you're gonna try to
find [ __ ] to tie up
dressing a whole mask and [ __ ] that's
like the new American Horror Story
all right awesome native I found my new
family they're over there
so you're going for like a Gothic thing
you're going for dark
he said the freaks come out at night
oh yes I'm looking to Wed some wenches
what's your top category in porn well
being autistic probably trained porn
this is not Europe okay it was an
autistic joke
that's like actually a category that is
a category getting a train run I don't
know like I dabble with a little bit of
everything like I like lesbian porn
because I'm bisexual
um
oh
DP
DP DP huh like mouth and that or two in
the veg double penetration
ouch
I gotta tie someone up to do that there
you go hey oh use it ouch
do you think you two would go on a date
ever
[Laughter]
listen
maybe it's friends
that's what you want a friend date right
Frank that's what you came here friends
yeah that's how Rose finds her sex
partners there you go
hey we're gonna have our first threesome
on other people
[Laughter]
you guys are both gonna be bossed around
by Rose
for him
yeah
so what uh what what do you uh have to
say to Chloe right now anything to you
know sort of winner over at the last
minute a little buzzer beater no no no
real point in winning over women like if
they're not interested they're not
interested there you go I don't chase I
attract I dig it hell yeah okay well
don't [ __ ] them fine by me fine whatever
just trying to bring you guys together
there goes the finale of the show
Chloe are you think you have to say to
Frank
don't tie any [ __ ] up tomorrow night
what if they like it yeah don't do it
don't do it it's just like you can
rebuttal you can hit her back with some
[ __ ] do you guys want to talk in zeros
and ones is that easier
Morse code it's a real binary over here
uh but yeah that's great advice that you
can leave or take Frank you know yeah
in costume
okay
yeah don't speak for a spectrum lady
some of us Norms like to be tied up it's
completely normal but I feel like if a
play doctor was like over me that's
probably he's probably a little too much
yeah that's better that's nice of you
that's a nice BDSM Dom over here
whatever you want
uh but yeah thank you guys for being on
the show give it up for Frank Garza
and Chloe
autistic
daters
that was a show thank you guys so much
for coming out anything you want to plug
Gina
um you can just find me on Instagram at
eggs and hot sauce me and Hans are going
to be doing a casino in December oh yeah
yeah we're gonna be doing Springfield
Massachusetts
all of you guys with extra mileage
points yeah go to the city in Boston in
Massachusetts that's not Boston no it's
it's a [ __ ] you've never been I've
never been I can't wait for you to see
it
terrible this is where Gina is from I am
about to be mercilessly heckled and
bullied on stage absolutely
sauce that's my Twitter that's my
Instagram I don't have a real YouTube
channel I don't want to be like that so
yeah thank
you I had a lot of fun thank you guys so
much have a good night drive safe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]